في ردود الفعل على الاقتحام ايضا قال على
من العام لحزب الله اللبناني حسن نصر الله
قبل قليل قال ان التعرض عن المقدسات
وللمسجد الاقصى من قبل الاسرائيليين قد
يفجر المنطقه بكاملها ودعا نصر الله الى
كبح جماح من وصفهم بل متطرفين تفاديا
لاندلاع حرب في المنطقه
الى صوت كل فصائل المقاومه في فلسطين
وعقول
ان
التعرض للمسجد الاقصى وللمقدسات الاسلاميه
والمسيحيه في فلسطين وفي بيت المقدس خصوصا
من قبل هؤلاء الصهاينه لن يفجر الوضع داخل
فلسطين فقط بل قد يفجر المنطقه بكاملها
ونقول لكل الدول في العالم
وليروعات هذا الكيان الغاصب اذا كنتم لا
تريدون حربا ثانيه في المنطقه
امام ما يجري في الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
فعليكم ان تذبحوا جناح هؤلاء المجانين
المتطرفين المتشددين